[Music]
this morning on the dish from stand-up
comedian to soup maker born and raised
in Washington DC Sarah Pollan spent
several years pursuing a career in
comedy on the stand-up circuit here in
New York but when she tired of the grind
she went back home and ended up starting
a business recalling her mother's
excellent soups she persuaded Marilyn
Pollan to join her and creating
Supergirl specializing in healthy
plant-based creations they now have
their own stores and a thriving delivery
business and a growing list of retail
partners including Whole Foods and
Costco
Sarah Pollan good morning and welcome to
the day thank you thank you for having a
fabulous spread what are we having okay
not too shabby here we have a basically
summer is on the tape yeah we have a
lentil corn dill salad with fennel and
peppers and cucumbers we have a
plant-based tomato basil caprese salad
with this meal goes vegan mozzarella
this is gorgeous this is the main course
this is whole wheat pasta and white
beans tossed together with a homemade
summer tomato sauce here we have a
delicious quinoa tabouli
we have our signature beet gazpacho and
then for dessert we have our peach crisp
topping with a vegan ice cream and then
of course because it's poncho oh my gosh
the tomatoes are so in season I read
your bio mhm the stand-up comedian
transferring to soup maker that just had
me what were you thinking I don't know I
think my mother's been doing that as
well no one should ask their mother what
I asked of mine but basically I had
veered away from comedy and was a little
lost and I wanted to start my own
business and at the same time I I was
very fortunate to have this aha moment I
read Michael Pollan's book The
Omnivore's Dilemma
and that talks about the industrial food
system and I was one of those people who
went to farmers markets and I thought
like farmers were cute you know it was
adorable and I didn't realize the impact
of our food choices on our bodies on the
health of the planet on our
Unity's and so I wanted to get involved
and I didn't know where to start and a
friend of mine said you know what your
mom makes really good soups so she and I
got into the kitchen she taught me
everything I know about cooking and we
just started cooking and it grew from
there were there things from comedy they
had living or the need to sort of shift
on the fly that like transferred there
are must be things that right yeah well
to the brand into the kitchen so first
of all when you're cooking soup I kind
of feel like a mad scientist I am NOT a
wonderful Baker I learned to like with
soup you can just like you go to the
market you look at what's in your
kitchen and you just start creating and
you spices and have fun and then you
make a mess and it's hilarious it's
really fun and then in the brand I try
to infuse humor and approachability
because food can be daunting yeah food
can be intimidating but when you add a
touch of humor it becomes fun you even
have humor I would say I hope in your
mom's title chief anxiety officer I
think everybody's mother could be that
right she takes that role very soon
she's supermom aka chief anxiety officer
so if anybody needs anything that they
need someone to worry about she'll take
care of it yes and being a small
business owner there's plenty to worry
about so she takes care of that and then
I just go ahead and keep working what
makes a good soup okay so soup soup is
more than food it really is its memory
it's it's like a hug from your mom you
have been given a bit of a bad rep over
the past couple of years because a lot
of companies put a lot of salts your
food put a lot of additives but our
soups if you didn't find an ingredient
in my mother's kitchen you're not gonna
find it in our suit what is it if you
can't say it again right like if your
grandmother can't pronounce an
ingredient why are you eating it yeah
and so those that's the essence of our
soups and a well-made bowl of soup is
the perfect food you can get plant-based
protein and fiber and hydration and and
hopefully a ton of flavor remember no
chemicals or salt are near low chemicals
also part of his book music I can't make
it if you can't couldn't make it 150
years ago like don't make it or eat it
today a little bit food is and I might
get destroyed on social media of this
but like food is I think very objective
you're gonna be hard-pressed to find a
doctor that says you really shouldn't be
eating a lot of plant-based protein and
fiber vegetables you should really stay
away from that and go for more for the
processed food why do we have this
notion of indulging in processed food
and ice cream and pizza indulge in this
yeah indulge in this you're gonna feel
good - yes indulging if you'd like to
indulge me with anyone while you're
signing the dish
tell us who would that be so I I think I
have it can I should say Alice Waters
because she found it really she's
amazing but I kind of want to say
Madonna sir Pollan thank you so much
thanks bye and for more on Sarah and the
dish head to our website at
cBS This Morning Calm